have you thought about justice for barb
I've thought about it about a lot about
giving money to the organization
attending the vigil attending the vigil
I know that there's actually a vigil I
saw that in Massachusetts yes close to
where I'm from
are you know that there's over a
thousand people going to this vigil is
that hilarious
amazing it's ridiculous and it's really
close from a Friday yeah I think uh me
and my dad are gonna go let's talk about
the ending I want to know your thoughts
yeah yeah so Nancy went team Steve yeah
I remember reading that me and a me and
Charlie and Natalia all sat down we got
the final scripts and we read it and I
really like what really
I was pretty pretty shocked but I think
it's really it's a really interesting
direction that they went it's kind of
built on this trope at least for Steve's
character for the first half of the
series and then towards you know like
the last to its last two or three
episodes they just kind of turn this
character around and it's kind of a
refreshing take on the 80 bully I guess
yeah I kind of expect him at the end I
was like Steve's had a punk out he's
gonna run away right at the end and no
yeah totally actually a good guy so are
you as Joe teams over team Jonathan
first a former some team barber yes team
barb thank you yeah I love barb us what
do you hope for Steve in season 2 I'm
just kind of interested to see like you
know now that everybody's in on it what
happens now and you know where do we go
from there and obviously his
relationship with Nancy his wallet right
I think um kind of what got him into the
whole thing I think he really cares
better stuff will say I don't know you
thought it was all gonna tie up them and
all of a sudden it's like hoppers leave
a negative sudden ease tossin that goes
down and then you got you know yeah will
coughing up bugs and stuff that's bad
yeah and hopefully season due to starts
vigil for barb
you